so uh hi my name is Amanda I am a senior
majoring in biochemistry in Columbia
College and I currently work with
Professor Virginia Cornish in who's
based in the Department of Chemistry
here at Columbia but I specifically work
on doing biochemistry research and my
project is actually focusing on doing
work within the ribosome and so to kind
of just give you some background the
title of my poster here is
discrimination of the amino acid by the
translational machinery and so to kind
of start giving you some introduction
back in 1958 Francis Crick actually came
up with the idea hypothesis which has
become somewhat of the dogma of the
ribosome field stating that the mRNA
codon and the tRNA anticodon is pretty
much like the money area of the ribosome
and this is how the body makes proteins
and peptides and so stating that has
actually become the dogma one of our
recent grad students in our lab did a
project on natural amino acids comparing
them to Miss isolated naturals and so
basically right here you see the scheme
and here is where you're finding the
natural amino acids so tRNA alanine with
tyranny with alanine and as the amino
acid finality is amino acid with the
tRNA phenylalanine and lysine with a
tRNA lysine and then with a simple
chemistry were actually able to miss ASA
Lacy's so for instance here you're
seeing tRNA phenylalanine with the
lysine amino acid and using our
translational machinery and our actually
our ribosome trans translation assays he
did a couple experiments comparing these
with the relative dipeptide yields
comparing to the naturals as well as
doing a selection competition assay and
what we found is actually that these
miss isolated now
amino acids are actually going in with
pretty much the same efficiency as the
natural amino acids showing that the
debry Besson was really not
discriminating against these miss
isolated naturals which was a really
interesting find and so kind of stepping
to the side of his project I'm actually
looking at DiMeo acids right here and so
here's a subset of the amino acids that
I meant looking at right now and these
are all charged on to tRNA lysine and
the difference between Naturals and D
amino acids is that DS is just a slight
stereochemistry difference and so for
instance here this amino group it's
pointing out and the natural it would be
pointing back and so using these I'm
also using the same translational and
machinery entrance in vitro translation
system that we have incorporated in our
lab to do these same type of dipeptide
experiments to look at selection and
specifically I'm looking at tRNA pairing
effects now and so here's just the
portrayal of a ribosome craft that I
actually did this past summer it's just
a very difficult irritation process and
so I just like to kind of show that this
is one of the components that goes into
doing the whole translation system and
then down here we're showing the use of
the flexitime ribozyme which is how we
actually put these miss isolated amino
acids onto the tRNA of choice and so
simply just by labeling the amino acid
with a DBE we're able to put whatever
amino acid of choice onto the tRNA of
choice as well and then here is just an
example of some of the results that I
have of aminoacylation with D amino
acids showing that their percentages are
relatively the same in this case but
really with the amino acyl Asians it
depends on what tRNA are using it
depends on what amino acid you can see
as much as a 52% charging as low as an
8% charging and so here's just a scheme
of the differences in meal
and then moving forward from that once
you get everything I mean amino acyl
ated we're actually able to move forward
and do experiments and so here we're
showing I'm showing some preliminary
data of looking at the different D amino
acids on tRNA lysine against the natural
lysine tRNA lysine and we're looking at
again dipeptide yield translations and
so here we're showing is that the lysine
tRNA lysine is going to 90 95 percent
and a half an hour a deal I saying
Ontario icing is also going to almost 80
percent but as you move away from the
deal icing on the tRNA lysine using
different G amino acids you're actually
showing that their yields are actually
changing which is different than what
we've found with the Mis isolated
natural is that the the ribosome really
isn't discriminating against these so
it's interesting to kind of move forward
and see where we're going to find where
these discrimination defects are
actually occurring in the ribosome and
this is where my project is going to be
continuing from there on